[Music]
each week Scania speaks to hundreds of
people Prime Minister's royalty
celebrities sporting stars we also speak
to ordinary people with extraordinary
tales to tell
no just some of the stories that they've
told us over the last year when we
arrived at a huge refugee camp in
northern Syria the staff couldn't locate
Shamima Begum the British teenager who
joined is in 2015 but we found her quite
by chance in a porter cabin after she
had given birth and she agreed to do an
interview so here it is a challenging
conversation that would make headlines
around the world what was it about
Islamic state that attracted you what
did you like about it
you really showed how you can go they'll
take care of you you can have your own
family there you can do anything you're
living under Islamic law did you know
what Islamic state we're doing when you
left for Syria because they had beheaded
people there were executions and I was I
was ok with there at first because you
know I want I started becoming religious
really just just before I left you know
from Y heard that islamically that is
all allowed so I was ok with it
the head of the Foreign Intelligence
Service is in the UK says people like
you are potentially very dangerous what
would you say to him they don't have any
evidence against me doing anything
dangerous when I went to Syria I was
just housewife in time for years stayed
home to care about me to care my kids I
never did anything dangerous and in my
talk and I never encouraged people
coming serious
do you feel that you have made a mistake
in coming here living under Islamic
state in a way yes but I don't regret
because I it's changed me as a person
it's made me stronger tougher
I married my husband I wouldn't have
found someone like him back in the UK I
had my kids I did have a good time down
it's just at the end things got hard and
I couldn't take anymore in a Kurdish run
jail in northern Syria the young Muslim
convert nicknamed jihadi Jack gave his
first interview since his parents back
home in Oxford were convicted of funding
terrorism by sending him money our
questions were put to Jack let's buy a
local journalist - 60 year-old atheists
being convicted for Islamic terrorism
doesn't really make much sense I feel
guilty for what I put them through in
that being said they didn't actually do
anything wrong they certainly money to
to leave etc and they've been actually
they saw were actually funding some sort
of terrorist activities I really want to
see them any more than I've ever wanted
even in my whole life for me being more
than 2 years not being able to him like
like I said my mother's voice is sort of
a big deal for us we were very close
family dinners my best friend Jack let's
was only a school boy when he left home
in May 2014 he said he wanted to learn
Arabic in Jordan four months later he
called his mother to say that he was in
Syria I wanted to fight the regime like
anything I never fought anyone except
for the region he says he became
disillusioned when he was out there I
think I left a time when Isis wasn't
actually falling in on itself I left
because I opposed them I genuinely
opposed then I was put in prison three
times by Isis and then escaped from them
they've done make sense being against
the regime I think is a good thing but I
definitely was with the wrong people in
that sphere something I learned a long
time ago
now let's is asking to come home I know
it doesn't it seems a bit far-fetched at
the moment but I'd love to go home
Britain's laughing of course I wanna go
British people like I said they're my
people but not sure they'd agree with
that
I have no attention flowing him up
that's probably important is growing
political pressure tonight for the
government to press the United States
over the case of an American woman who
claimed diplomatic immunity after being
involved in an accident in which a 19
year old man died their son was killed
when he was hit by a car believed to
have been driven by the wife of an
American diplomat and cyclist who has
since claimed diplomatic immunity we
just don't understand from one human to
another and one mum to another how you
could just get on a plane and leave
behind the devastation that she has if
she doesn't come back Harry's parents
may be able to sue her in the u.s. we
were sincerely hoping as parents that
she'd have enough heart to be able to
come forward we still do hope that's the
case
but if it's not then yeah we will piss
you the Foreign Secretary had asked the
u.s. to do the right thing
Harry's family just want to know what
happened they entered the Foreign Office
craving action after a 45-minute meeting
there was nothing new everybody else in
the world can see what she's done is
wrong
why can't they see that
I feel like I'm being an idiot because I
can see it we can all see it we can't
the two most powerful men in the
whatever why can't they see
[Music]
sallie Challen met her husband Richard
when she was just 15 they married had
two sons and were together 40 years the
outside world a happy family what people
didn't see was that sally was a victim
of sustained psychological abuse a crime
now recognized as coercive control
mental abuse is the most difficult thing
to explain to people I think that over
the years mine was like a drip feed
coming at me
and it came to a crescendo at the end
it's something that makes you question
your own mind and in August 2010 after
suspecting Richard have yet another
affair she snapped I gave him his food
and I said to him am I going to see you
tomorrow and he said don't question me
don't question me and I grabbed a hammer
that was in my bag and hit him they say
I hit him 18 times
I can't think that I could possibly have
been capable of doing something
something he just snapped inside me by
the time my trial had come up I dropped
considerably mentally and it was just a
blur all I can really remember is being
asked questions and answering
I suppose so I suppose so I think the
main thing that I remember is my eldest
son screaming at my sentence I thought
I'd die in prison I didn't think there
was any hope but hope came when coercive
control was made a crime while sally was
behind bars it allowed her lawyers to
fight to change her case to manslaughter
ultimately leading to her release it was
surreal really walking out of there but
I want to help those that are still
there who shouldn't be there they need a
voice and I think I have to be that
voice for them it was right that I went
to prison but i reaiiy think the charge
and the conviction was wrong now that I
say that I've come out the other side I
want to help other people fight for
justice
almost 300 climate change activists have
been arrested in a second day of
protests in central London the tactics
of defiance and direct action are aimed
at getting maximum publicity for their
cause the point of it is to keep this
Laurie here as we keep the Laurie here
then we keep the road and if we keep the
road then because there's a sir up ssin
that we need to create none of us really
want to be creating disruption but we're
being forced to do that because we've
been completely ignored for the past 30
years on what is now the most
unprecedented ly broad and deep
emergency crisis that humans have ever
seen and where we're basically
committing suicide by not approaching it
with a sensible management head so
that's what we want to see from our
government and we're forcing the
government to come to the table about it
and that's what this is about
and I'd love to be able to do that with
petitions and I'd love to be able to do
that with a March but unfortunately
those haven't worked so here I am locked
to a lorry for 10 hours this first time
I've done this so it was really cause
we're in the middle of Waterloo Bridge
Street as you can imagine the wind again
it was going past but everyone's been
really kind and they've given us lots of
food and drink and blankets and things
and it's also a bit emotionally scary
because you know that you might get
arrested and what you don't know what
that's gonna be like necessarily but
overall there's a lot of support here
and I'd just hope that people understand
that we're doing this for everyone
and it's not just for us it's not about
trying to get attention we don't really
want to be here we're doing it for
everyone security
[Music]
gratitude berg is one of the world's
most famous climate activists at just 16
she's become the face of a global
movement inspiring millions of children
around the world to strike from school
when you look around the world there are
some countries that are taking action
the UK for example is committed to net
zero carbon emissions by 2050 is that
progress for you that depends on what
you define as progress if they are to
follow their carbon budgets to be in
line with first woman's to say below the
1.5 degrees of warming of pre-industrial
levels then I mean I sometimes want to
do they have like a secret carbon budget
that we don't know about because they
are being very proud of what they have
accomplished but I mean there is not
nearly enough if they are to do their
part what do you think it was about the
school strike and that idea that caught
the imaginations of so many people it
was just after a very hot summer with
lots of wildfires and droughts and
extreme weather in Sweden so many people
were worried about and concerned about
the climate like oh maybe this is
serious also because it is children it
is young people who are saying these
things that are saying like you're
stealing our future why should we care
about our future educating ourselves
it's new if you don't care about our
future and I think that is a very
powerful message
and people feel guilty when children
would say that
this week more evidence has emerged
about a drug called primo dose and it's
linked to potential birth defects it was
given to women in the 1960s and 70s as a
pregnancy test and the manufacturer has
always denied the link we produced a
documentary about this drug back in 2017
and since then a lot more victims have
come forward one of them I met earlier
this week called Linda Phillips well I
saw your documentary it describes how
women went to their doctors they were
given two tablets which was exactly what
happened to me I never put the
connection together until I saw that I
had a child that was stillborn and the
top of their head was missing the top of
her brain was missing and they told me
that they there was no reason why it was
one of those things that it would
probably never happen again go home try
again they they took the child away at
the delivery I never saw her I don't
know what they did with her I still
don't know to those this day where she
is you're very bright funny sense of
humor obviously but it's just people
people don't take the time to work that
out at home and it right known me I'm on
my own and I've never had I've made
millions like me has a relationship with
me Mommy has children
awesome one no one pin the girl no
yes I know plight picking
[Music]
really just one the same things as
everyone else and it's about quality not
difference
Freddie McConnell is one of only a
handful of men to have carried and
delivered his own baby while it may seem
strange to some to Freddie it should be
a choice accessible to many more trans
people he spoke to Sky News about the
experience I didn't ever get sort of
recognized as a trans man who was
carrying his own baby who was pregnant
it's amazing actually people just
thought I was a man with a beer belly he
was initially told testosterone would
make him infertile it didn't and now
he's fighting what he calls dangerous
misinformation in some countries around
the world trans people are obliged to
undergo sterilization in order to access
transition but by sort of paying so such
little attention to trans people's
wishes to start families and have full
lives and not just the lives that they
dictate through this kind of narrow
sense of what it is to transition it is
de facto sterilization have you come
across people who say or he just want to
have his cake and eat it and have you
responded to those people yeah I find
that a really strange idea I guess I
would ask people to examine to ask
themselves whether they remember they
want kids where they want a family like
if they don't fair enough as they do
there maybe we're not that different
[Music]
they've Merritt was pulling his car into
the garage when he saw his wife crying
and knew something was wrong
she'd just found out that their son had
been caught up in the London Bridge a
terror attack tonight he speaks for the
first time since his son's death and has
tough words for her the Prime Minister
responded in the immediate aftermath I
had seen reports on Twitter from about
2:00 o'clock that day that there had
been an incident at London Bridge I
didn't know jack was at London Bridge
that day when I got home my wife was
driving my car into the drive which
seemed to be odd and she was just beside
herself saying we've got to go to London
I've got to go to London and I said why
I've got to go to London and she said
because Jack has been involved in this
incident at London Bridge we got to
London
we got a taxi went to the Royal London
Hospital and waited and then we were
told at about quarter to 11:00 that they
confirmed that he had been killed so
that was how we found out the pain of
losing his son compounded in the days
that followed by what Dave sees as the
exploitation of Jack's death for
political gain immediately people start
jumping on the criminal-justice
bandwagon so you know advocating longer
sentences and harsher penalties you know
I spoke to Jack in a lot of detail about
his work and I knew how passionate was
about rehabilitation and helping people
to redeem themselves instead of seeing a
tragedy Boris Johnson saw an opportunity
and he went on the offensive it was
important that somebody said something
and that just happened to be me and
obviously my son's being killed
people are gonna listen to me
[Music]
well it's certainly been a big year in
politics but still no brexit instead we
have a general election three years
after the historic referendum votes to
leave Sky News spoke to the man who put
it in motion the former Prime Minister
David Cameron he's been hiding away from
the political spotlight for three years
but this week David Cameron burst back
onto the scene the release of his
memoirs so I sat down with him to
reflect on his time as Wonderstone
you're a student of history does it pain
you that you'll go down in history is
the man who put brexit in motion well it
pains me what I see has happened since
because we've had three years of hiatus
we seem stuck now to be fair to Theresa
May she produced a deal for us to leave
the EU and I think it was wrong for the
people who most wanted brexit to reject
that deal which is why we are where we
are but as I try to explain in the book
that I believed our position in the EU
was becoming unsafe and unstable
particularly after the treaty veto in
2011 where we had genuine concerns but
the EU just pushed ahead and had a
treaty anyway same people same offices
same table same chairs and it showed
they could do things without unanimity
we needed to fix that and that is where
the renegotiation and the referendum
came from and I believe they are
inevitable well let's talk about your
equity in government then and because
the many people your government was
symbolic of austerity between 2010 and
2016 the number of people sleeping rough
doubled food bank usage went up I mean
you were talking about compassionate
conservatism is that the record of
compassionate consult as a record of the
government is that we cut the budget
deficit by two-thirds we created two and
a half million jobs there are a million
more businesses we became the
fastest-growing economy in the g7
inequality fell the number of people in
poverty fell the number of households
where no one worked fell massively and
we ended up with an economy with more
people in work and at any time in our
history I'm been quiet than are three
years sometimes driven me mad to hear
that somehow austerity was a political
choice that there were other
alternatives we faced a clear and
present
danger of having such a massive budget
deficit we had to sort that out you've
been in the background shall we say for
a couple of years now and they have now
burst back onto the political scene
doing a lot of interviews you can fall
to gain back the Shepherd's are having a
bit of a quiet life I was very lucky
when I first became Tory leader every
single previous story leader was on my
side briefly I mean Margaret Thatcher
John major Michael Howard in dung Smith
William Hague and it gives you an
enormous ability and strength to get on
with the job so I will try not to be
what Linton Crosby used to call Connie
the commentator but from time to time
I'm sure I'll have something to say but
I'm looking forward you know what is
what I wanted to you know say my piece
about the book and let people read it
and judge it for themselves but I
promise this this camp Fest is coming to
an end we just about see the gates of
Downing Street behind me now earlier
White's always packed Parliament Square
was packed it was all very noisy and I'm
delighted to say some of the diehards
are still here why have you come here
tonight the past years this has been
going on I've not had a voice so this is
my opportunity to get my voice hard and
to get it out there that I'm not happy
with this and I'm not happy I'm
Portuguese and I worked here for 20
years and I have no voice and the
resettlement scheme is not working all
right
have you been joining the protest today
I have finally I have because I need a
voice I worked and I gave this country
my youth and very grateful for what you
taught me
but you must make me part of all this
process yeah I can't really be kicked
out I build things for you I looked
after your children I looked after their
elderly in this country now you kick me
out with what with what I am very very
hurt by what they've done to England
because I came here and I joined the
working force and I'm very proud of it
so I'm very angry at them
this country look who I found
Stanley Johnson no no your life go on
I'm fine you just arrived just got off
the train right wonderfully back in
Manchester what are you thinking well
I'm thinking that this is the moment
when we're all going up you know crack
it yeah it's gonna be gonna be a fine
fine event and I know this as I walk
through the streets together everybody's
saying well hi well done
so I'm very pleased to be here yeah I'm
sure you are a bit of a challenge for
your little boy yes that's what little
boys are for isn't it I mean you know
they have to get through life's
challenges is Pepsi Willis public school
this University you know it's the first
step in the in the run and then there's
the big step and I think he's going to
handle it absolutely fine
kids are not necessarily getting on
their other son our family is united
united we all think what we think and we
know that whatever happens was like fine
so perhaps we could just go back very
quickly to asking about whether what
Boris giving an American businesswoman
cash no while he was mayor of London
whether that was appropriate or not you
wouldn't any is one of our Tuffy's don't
dash away because we've got your bag
[Music]
Sky News has travelled far and wide over
the past twelve months to bring you the
stories that matter from natural
disasters to terrorist attacks mass
protests to moments in history here is
just a few the terrible fire at not
radar saw hundreds of years of history
disintegrate in minutes I was among the
crowds gathering and looking on as the
blaze began to take hold we tried to
capture the emotions of France as a
building that embodies its spirit like
no other looked close to being lost that
night was the start of a week of deep
sadness reflection but also a
determination to rebuild
[Music]
Agnes Quarrie a is Paris born and bred
and not true Dom has been a constant in
her lifetime she was mesmerized by what
she witnessed overnight and terrified
she would wake to Paris without its
much-loved Cathedral you know a lot of
people through the night came there
there was nothing they could do but they
were there some of them you know it was
finally praying or even there I could
have here some singing and some people
staring and hoping also that finally you
know they were applauded throughout the
nights I could hear it so sort of you
know the community gathering and I'm
hoping that the British journalist
Robert Hardman made it inside not
freedom last night as the battle to save
the cathedral was under way the photos
he took showed the damage unfolding
around him there was two or three inches
of water on the floor terrible smell
ready hits the back of your throat
really strong smell and yet through the
the clouds of water still coming down
from above from the fireman's hoses and
the flames and everything else suddenly
this fireman's torch picked out this
extraordinary image at the far end and
there was a crucifix across the gold
crosses it's known still on the altar
sort of it's somehow stayed standing and
I think it just this morning it's a very
powerful image for a lot of people in
France we are in Holy Week this is a one
of the most sacred spots in France and I
think people many people see perhaps
some sort of divine intervention
hundreds dead hundreds more injured
churches and hotels targeted in one of
the worst terror attacks of recent times
I spoke to mark Campbell whose mother
Lorraine died in the Srilanka attacks so
the day of the bobbins husband Neal he
rang me to let me know that it was her
hotel and that he'd been texted her when
she was in the restaurant having
breakfast and we could you know the
other person that was with her I lost
his life and I guess we kind of knew the
kind of the side I'll take from it is
it's one anything she had the same when
it's your time it's home it's not really
decided by us I guess it was at home
[Music]
teenagers Emily and Danny Lindsay were
among the Britons killed in the attacks
they were on the last day of a holiday
to Sri Lanka with their father who was
not seriously injured I spoke to their
brother David as they're running they
were caught in the in the second
explosion by the accent I think my dad
had literally been it been a couple
meters behind behind my sister and my
brother and just from the way that the
blast fell he survived almost untouched
yes he has a few cuts on his face and
he's obviously extremely shaken and
distraught she was really the glue that
held the family together and all of us
just we still have like an indescribable
bond with her and she's left
unimaginably big shoes to fill and
remember and be very hard to continue
without her really what he loved just
getting out of his comfort zone meeting
people no man and what that background
were they were from who befriend
everyone and everyone he met always
loved him please he was such a pure soul
[Music]
see the professors are right in their
faces
they're some of the biggest protests
Hong Kong has ever seen
hundreds of thousands of demonstrators
on the streets angry at plans to change
extradition laws I questioned
pro-democracy activist Joshua Wong
shortly after he was freed from prison
what we asked for is when two millions
people come to join the rally KLM should
take a lesson to learn what about
respect
what we asked for is not only suspend
the bill oppose the legislation process
we are not sure when will the papel off
communist regime ship executive to
reactivate the bill in the future that's
why what we ask for is withdraw we've
seen a lot of protests peaceful protests
with millions on the street we've also
seen violent process what's the next
step for you now if you don't think
she's listening now the movement is more
organic self-initiative the central life
and also showing the power and
determination of people I hope people
could aware that if the government
ignore our wars in the next one to two
weeks more action demonstration massive
mobilization will happen is not
mobilized by any leader from the
Democratic camp is just mobilized by
Carolyn
[Music]
these shanty towns never stood a chance
against the most powerful hurricane the
Bahamas has ever experienced the
Bahamian Prime Minister said his islands
were at war with hurricane Dorian and
looking down here that was no
exaggeration they have been ravished
small sailboats were no match for this
monster even large vessels were rendered
flimsy in the face of gusts exceeding
200 miles per hour so we're on the
ground here in one of the worst affected
areas this was the harbor completely
obliterated palm trees obviously
completely flattened the boats
themselves lifted clean out of the water
onto the land like during the hurricane
total terrifying here almost drowned we
held it door closed for 2 hours 30 years
and you watched it
disappear yeah when I look up again I
look right up in the sky so who you here
and you're smiling and you say girl you
gotta get Botox
god is good
[Music]
upbeat even if seemingly under siege a
whistleblower claims Rudy Giuliani was
part of a push to get Ukraine to dig for
dirt on Joe Biden he says he did nothing
wrong and the State Department knew
exactly what he was doing the State
Department asked me to help them deal
with the Ukrainian government with
regard to meetings with President Trump
State Department investigate crime I was
asked to do this by the State Department
I didn't know mr. Yarmouk from a hole in
the wall the name of uremic was given to
me by Kurt Vogel ambassador I was asked
to meet with him I did me with him i
briefed them two of them on everything I
did and I have a very nice text at the
end explaining how honest and
straightforward I was which is which I
am you don't have any issue with a
foreign power investigating a political
rival of the president I do if you
didn't do anything
but if he bribed the president of that
country I have an issue if they don't
invest me how the heart of this we know
is a whistleblower who alleges that the
president tried to interfere with the
2020 election the White House covered it
up do you in principle regard both of
those things as potentially serious
offenses so here's what he says here's
what he says I am deeply concerned I was
told I heard based on my understanding I
learned I do not know you know you know
the word isn't here the verb that isn't
here no there's no place here I know I
know
I know he's not a witness to anything he
heard gossip he's telling you what other
people said to him most of which when
you look at that recording turn out to
be wrong are you at all concerned about
your future because you very have seen
places a central role in this no I'm not
concerned about my future what I did is
perfectly lawful perfectly legal you're
asking me about the process that I
followed to uncover
the biggest scandals I should be
considered a whistleblower
I should be getting whistleblower
protection I actually found facts that
are true the other guy half of what he
wrote is false
[Music]
20:19 has been a memorable year of sport
England's cricketers were crowned
world's champions in dramatic style at
Lourdes while it was nearly but not
quite for the lionesses and for the
men's rugby team at their respective
World Cups away from the pitch
Lewis Hamilton secured his sixth Formula
One world title Anthony Joshua reclaimed
his heavyweight belts and Dena Asha
Smith became the first British woman to
win a major global sprint title
there'll be so much focus on you
building up to Japan how do you deal
with that a lot of pressure now I just
keep going like normal from being honest
yeah I think I'm getting a bit more
comfortable with there being more
attention I think if you ask me a few
years or even last year I would have
been like oh no no please just just
don't look at me kind of and I'm still a
bit like that don't get me don't get me
wrong but I think I've kind of
interpreted as people want you to do
well and people are hoping that you do
well which is absolutely lovely
obviously people with hopes and
aspirations are completely distinct from
the hard work that I still need to do
and it's distinct from what actually
might happen on track because you still
got to put in the work to be successful
but it's just well wishes and it's
really nice that so many people want me
to do well what does the build up then
look like to Tokyo so between now and
then training train loads are hard work
training I've probably start racing at
about May juni time which I'm not
completely sure about but definitely
making sure that we're at the mill
anniversary Games in the summer which
I'm so excited for because that would be
actually the first opportunity that I'm
able to stand in front of a British
crowd as a world champion which is a
crazy thought but yeah what's your dream
when you think through you know forward
to July to the Olympics yeah and do you
can you allow yourself to think about
collecting oh no no we don't think about
that simply because I have to train so
hard to get there and then I have to
race I have to make the team and I have
to get their injury free so there are a
few quite a few small but significant
hurdles that you have to overcome before
you can even think about the Olympics
and even when you do you don't start
thinking about the result afterwards
when you've got to do the races first so
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a historic moment for England
extraordinary scenes here England have
won the World Cup for England's
cricketers this is the day this is the
moment this is history
the morning after England's historic
handing probable World Cup win thousands
of fans gathered at the oval to meet him
congratulate the conquering team
I spoke to England's batsman Joe root
for years after the back of it very
difficult World Cup in Australia
everything that we've been through on
this journey together as a team bad
things
wonderful times on the fields going
close together off the floor we also
play of thinking back to the bad times
what I mean is you've been through it
all you have experienced it all and now
again to enjoy yesterday for what it
wasn't really able to see other a duty
of care to look after the game leave it
in a better place and hopefully inspire
next generation to go on and do things
we played extremely well yeah but Lorenz
Stokes the partnership they put on to
get us back into the game
yeah that doesn't happen by by mistake
and that happens by a lot of hard work
away from the game you know and a lot of
confidence the hot air that look the
whole the whole team has been a part of
four years of planning and and it's
really a culmination of those four years
and you're certain you see these these
young guys here now in their in their
mid-20s at the end of this yeah with a
smile on their face and if you see some
of their have a look at some of the
photos in the paper this morning they
could be 14 years old seven years old
playing with their mates in the backyard
and that's that's the best thing about
the game of cricket
a man to make is to to change how people
think and actually sure the sport is a
really a positive whereby they can unify
people and not to say the towel fitter
and tell me the people who turned out
today the people of Vienna all over the
world in Kenya today for you and what do
you say to the fans to say thank you and
I hope that there used is not mine alone
history is among all the citizens of
Vienna all over to leukemia today watch
the YouTube in facebook following
Twitter those who are thrive in their
televisions to get away of my district
some reason I said one last request this
year also saw a new edition for the
royal family with the two conductors of
Sussex welcoming their son Archie into
the world we also caught up with a
global icon and had some fun on set the
Dutchess of Sussex has gone into labor
at Prince Harry is by her side who's
Harry has announced that his wife the
Duchess of Sussex has given birth to a
baby boy Prince Harry could not have
looked any happier a beaming new dad he
personally wanted to tell the world
about his new son I'm very excited to
announce that myself had a baby boy
early this morning a very healthy boy
mother and baby are doing incredibly
well it's been the most amazing
experience I can ever possibly imagine
how any woman does what they do is
beyond comprehension but we're both
absolutely thrilled and so grateful to
all the love and support from everybody
out there that's been that's been
amazing so I just wanted to share this
with everybody excitement in Windsor is
mounting as well fans wait to see the
new arrival for the very first time as
you can see the champagne has already
been open there's been flying oh no I
think we couldn't be in the Target I'm
getting a cork in the eye but let's try
and put a quick words before impales
archie Harrison and mountbatten-windsor
was introduced to the world today by his
proud parents Prince Harry and the
Duchess of Sussex magic it's pretty
amazing
[Music]
and I have the two best guys in the
world so I'm
it's only been three days I have slowly
starts to grow up
she's the golden girl of country famous
for her enormous hair glamorous outfits
and catchy music that was way ahead of
its time Dolly Parton's in town to
promote the London debut of a hit
musical 95 and I caught up with my music
idol dolly it's an absolute pleasure to
meet you well thank you how are you
feeling of about 95 musical hitting the
London stage well I'm feeling excited
more than anything I cannot wait to see
y'all the new cast up there doing all
the songs that I've written for the play
and it's almost 40 years since the film
came out I mean oh are you surprised but
it still resonates with so many people
it's just like it won't die it's the
gift that keeps on givin cuz 9 to 5 as
you know we did that in 79 it came out
in 80 and that was part of my deal was
that I would pop the theme so I mean you
hope for the best you hope you get a
good song when you did write that song
back in the 70s
40 years on a women where you thought
they would be 40 years old do you think
there's still a long way to go well I
think there's gonna always be a long way
to go it's just a work in progress as
life itself is especially women in the
workplace when you look back over your
life you know 26 number ones the most
decorated country music star you know
you're an absolute icon but also your
literacy project and the money that
you've pumped back into Pigeon Forge
with dolly dolly world what do you think
you'd be most proud of well I'm proud of
all of it I have to answer save because
you never know when you start out how
you're going to be known or thought of
when you're older you hope for the best
but I'm really proud of the imagination
library that the project that I've done
where we give books to children but I've
been very proud of everything that I've
accomplished to be in the Songwriters
Hall of Fame because my songwriting is
very important but I won't mind being
known as the book lady but I want to be
know
my music as well and to have left
something great in the world that wasn't
there before I can walk now it's not
often that our guests get away with
running around our studio and licking
the glass but will forgive little ila
and Jemima reen before they were born
the twins were diagnosed with a rare
blood imbalance which gave them just a
5% chance of survival the girls and
their parents came in for a chat on a
plane
this is Ayla they want to wander around
it's absolutely fine it worried about it
while we're having a chat
[Music]
[Laughter]
we'll see you in just a second
[Music]